CBS News senior foreign affairs
correspondent and Face the Nation
moderator Margaret Brennan joins us now
Margaret good morning given the
prominence of soleimani in the Middle
East how is Iran reacting to this
killing and what kind of response should
the u.s. expect going forward this is a
seismic event this is huge
and there is really shocked that this
escalation took place the Trump
administration is saying it wants to
de-escalate and this targeted
assassination of Qasem Soleimani is
likely to have the opposite effect this
is like taking out another country
taking out the CIA director of the vice
president the United States yes sulemani
was considered a terrorist but he was a
right-hand man to Iran's supreme leader
he was a revered general and all of this
is happening at a time the Iranian
regime is financially desperate and
they've been struggling under US
sanctions but killing sulemani may
actually help unify Iran Iran's supreme
leader has already named his deputy head
of the Revolutionary Guards so the group
he led is not going away even though the
leader and the strategist is gone
Margaret soleimani as we've been
reporting has been a major military
force in the region for years but
previewed previous presidents have
elected not to target him because of the
potential impact so so what do you think
was buying the president's decision to
do it now Anthony this is an act of war
that is why past presidents have stopped
short of it president Trump's decision
it is certainly a bold one but we have
very little detail into what made him
make this decision there was silence
across the national security community
last night and Secretary of State Pompeo
is not giving a lot of detail this
morning but saying there was an active
imminent plot against the United States
what's unusual in that is that Qasem
Soleimani has been directing imminent
attacks against US interests for years
particularly the past two and a half
years and the Trump administration has
been piling sanctions on Iran none of it
has stopped Iran's aggressive behavior
so president Trump has taken this more
extreme position of assassinating this
leader but we don't know what happens
next
Margaret in response to the you
air strikes on their soil Iraq's
Parliament is expected to vote to expel
US troops from the nation where the US
has a very large important presence
there what impact would that force
withdraw have on America's goals in that
region well this is so significant in
terms of the spillover effect this is a
really uncomfortable position for
Baghdad to be in and and what you raise
is a really key question because the US
troops are only there with the
permission and at the request of the
Iraqi government to carry out operations
in nearby Syria against terrorists and
to use Iraq as a base of operations to
do that we have at least 5,000 US troops
in Iraq what happens to their presence
does Iraq allow them to remain how big
does the US diplomatic presence and
intelligence presence remain inside of
Iraq so assassinating Qasem Soleimani on
Iraqi soil causes a lot of political
complications for the leaders of Iraq it
could destabilize Baghdad Margaret the
Pentagon is characterizing this as a
preemptive strike but I have to ask
could the fallout the counter strike the
potential counter strike will it put
American lives in danger well the
administration has said American lives
are in danger they're telling Americans
get out of Iraq now if you were there
the u.s. personnel have already been
drawn down over the past few months
we're at lower levels in terms of US
diplomats than we've been in quite some
time
you have to believe that today there are
conversations about considering taking
further action we've heard from mayors
across the United States in New York
City and other cities saying they're
looking domestically at security
procedures here on US soil and you've
seen the call logs just in the past few
hours from the Secretary of State
calling American allies in the UK and
France and Germany trying to reassure
them that this is not an attempt to
escalate things into a war but rather to
de-escalate those countries are
concerned that what remains of the
diplomatic deal with Iran to keep its
nuclear program frozen may now have gone
out the door yesterday with this
assassination there are a lot of
worst-case scenarios being talked about
and played out all right Margaret
Brennan thank you Margaret
you